blade smith's congratulations you've
made it into the third round of this
competition and now it's time to send
you back to your home forges to recreate
this iconic weapon from history that
weapon is
charlemagne's joyous
good luck we'll see you in four days
[Music]
all right it's day one today the plan is
to get the blade forged out
this is definitely out of the box for me
so this will be the first sword i ever
completely assembled we're gonna start
out with a bar of 1075 high carbon steel
we're going to do a lot of the quick
forging to shake with a power hammer
whenever you try to move a big piece of
metal like this it's quite a challenge
to keep it straight
it's getting uh
long and heavy and hard to hold
so end of day one good day we've got the
blade forged out it's cooling down
between a couple of two by sixes so that
way it doesn't warp as it cools down
tomorrow we'll get it ready for heat
treat
i'm back here in valentine nebraska and
i'm here to make charlemagne's joists
currently i've never made a sword before
this is going to be an interesting
experiment for me
so i'm going to use a big piece of 5160
bar stock it can take a lot of damage
and flex well
i want to make sure i got the length of
the blade done down to a reasonable size
so this steel is definitely the most
awkward thing that i've ever worked with
in the shop it's like a big wet noodle
end of day one i've got my blade
profiled
tomorrow the plan is i'm gonna start
heat treating and get this damascus
ready for the cross garden
it's the morning of day two now we're
going to get ready for heat treat the
main thing is i'm definitely paying
really close attention to the parameters
getting pretty close to coming up the
temperature so
we're about five minutes away and we'll
be quenching her
all right this is it
enrique
all right
well i'm worried that hitting the bottom
of the quench tank did some damage
come on man
i tried to fish it out but unfortunately
i didn't catch anything ended up pouring
it out in the five gallon bucket in my
yard i got the blade out so it's all
good now
i did pick up a slight wart close to the
tip i should be able to straighten that
out during the temper cycle
so
time will tell
morning of day three plan today is to
grind in my fullers and get all my
fittings ground down and shaped
so my biggest fear of putting in this
folder is just grinding right through my
blade i can kind of tell how close it is
just by feeling it with my hand
after about an hour the fuller's done
and everything is looking good
coming out pretty well
now i can work on profiling the pommel
and guard and getting them exactly to
where i want it
for my handle i choose diamond wood
because it can take a lot of abuse and
it's not going to break
i'm in the home stretch now tomorrow i'm
just going to be focusing on getting
everything fitted and glued together
it's a good looking piece so far
morning into day four i got a lot of
work ahead of me my biggest focus is
going to be getting the blade straight
and so i want to get that out of the way
and then go from there my solution is to
extend the width of the jaws with some
angle iron heat it up and use some
wooden dowels to put the proper pressure
where it needs to
be she's straight
oh that's so freaking awesome now i need
to make the handle
time's running out so it's a race to the
finish
all right she's getting there end of day
four
man it's been quite a trip everything
turned out great a lot of hard work but
i believe it really paid off in the end
that's a sword in four days
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
according to its historic design i will
take your weapon deliver some killing
slashes and thrusts on this for carcass
mitch europe you ready for this yes sir
all right mitch talk about your sword
here
your edge coupled with the weight that
you have here allows for very deep cuts
with every strike
overall sir
you'll kill thank you
all right peyton it's your turn you
ready oh yeah
[Music]
all right peyton
that was joyous
what i like about this sword is not just
about the edge or the point it's the
balance in this i can actually use some
velocity
and it cuts deep overall sir
it will kill thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
i will be attacking our armored knights
here
now this is not about what your blades
are going to do to that target about
what that target's going to do to your
blades
mitch here up first you ready for this
yes sir
i think i just peed a little
all right mitch your edge did take some
damage here you can see the chip
right there and some rolls and your
sword is heavy
you know this is a lot of weight for a
single hand sword more in the range of a
two-handed sword as far as the weight
goes but um she held up
she's
in one piece
good job mitch thank you
all right peyton you're up you ready
yeah
[Music]
all right peyton it's weighty but the
the weight is all back in my hand so it
doesn't feel
as heavy in the blade this sword has a
much better point of balance than the
other swords your blade did take some
chips and some edge rolling but i think
your grinds are beautiful the sword is
all solid you did a good job thank you
all right bladesmith welcome to the
sharpness test the sandbag gauntlet
now to test the sharpness of your weapon
i will slash across these bags now i
like to strengthen this is all about how
sharp your blades are and how well they
cut these bags
mitch europe first you ready yes sir
all right mitch so despite some of the
damage of rolls and chips it wasn't an
issue at all in cutting these bags
it will cut thank you
all right peyton your turns are you
ready yes sir
[Music]
all right peyton the handle construction
is smooth but oh void enough to where i
wrap my hand around it and i get a very
good grip you'll cut thank you
mitch payton the judge's deliberation is
complete you guys have done fantastic
work on these finale weapons but there
can only be one forged and fire champion
our new forged and fire champion is
payton congratulations you're the forza
fire champion mitch unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut mitch you
brought us a sword that performed well
in all three of our tests so this came
down to the finer points of
craftsmanship as in where to place the
balance point on that blade and the
general weight that balance point being
so far forward made it harder to wheel
and harder to control and that's why
we're letting you go i understand
mitch you've been a great competitor
this entire competition but at this time
i have to ask you to please surrender
your blade
obviously disappointed being my first
sword nothing to compare it to i thought
the weight felt good i tried to keep the
six to eight inches balance point that i
was told normally swords carry so
overall happy with what i turned in and
i'm happy for payton if i had to lose
anyone i just didn't lose to him
peyton congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check for 10 000
congratulations please present your
sword to the judges
i'm the next fortune fire champion ah
it's just crazy as soon as i heard my
name it's just like a weight just got
pulled off my chest just like
it's over
i finally can breathe
you